let's talk about the uh jake paul and
vanessa
ben askren fight benny ben ben um
you like ben askren you know
i kind of spoke nasty about him
on the moz on the jorge fight because
i was been asking to put my dick in your
mouth
oh nice nice how's it going
thanks man that's that's the one on the
board
that's definitely that definitely that's
a half point maybe it's a half time i
think it counts i didn't see it coming
literally yeah nice oh all right sorry
what were we saying
no i like i i kind of spoke if if the
internet delay wasn't here you would
have got that one
clean and clear hell yeah you would have
drained that from half court
sucks for the win
[Applause]
e5 e5
hey nice to e meet you send in an 85
your way
zoom professors be like let's get a
quick e5
nope okay okay cool
let's go ahead and open our books to
107.
let's rip a couple aspirin vids yeah
couple vids just to give the people a
little context on what we're talking
about
him and jake did a a press oppressor for
their fight
or whatever and it was a it was kind of
a funny
uh dynamic i would say funny energy yeah
because
ben clearly does not give a [ __ ] and
jake wants him to care
jake is doing the whole like like over
dramatic like we hate each other shtick
because because he's like trying to sell
more tickets
yeah and ben isn't playing into it and
it just leads it's just like
you can tell it's frustrating for jake
and so he does it even harder
and it's just not the dynamic is really
bizarre i think it's great because
that's you know naturally ben's age is
showing
and jake forgets that ben's literally
been in
close to 30 professional fights
so it's just like yeah i think for ben
it's like bro
i've stood in front of guys actually
scary
and a [ __ ] 22 year old who just
learned how to punch like a couple years
ago
i think i'm fine anyways yeah
rip the clip there we go
bro
little slap on the ass
dude get that [ __ ] ass out of here
before i eat it yeah yeah yeah yeah
get that [ __ ] stick 2cs out of here
ben cheeks out of here
before i stick my nose in a dog
don't mess up again before i i might
grip up on that thing next time
ben yeah play the homicide clip
yeah this [ __ ] is so funny you can't
fight dylan so you
pick the next person okay let me
continue
you said if i want if i wanted the
easiest person it would have been dylan
but you're saying i picked you because
because dylan one sent a contract
well i'm trying to wait for you to stop
talking okay so anyways
like this is typical boy behavior but
obviously sometimes
this is the [ __ ] wrong person this is
the [ __ ] fight game
you [ __ ] ass [ __ ] this is the [ __ ]
fight game
yeah i'll bully you around just like i'm
gonna bully you in the ring shut the
[ __ ] up
you sound like a middle schooler oh he's
bullying me shut the [ __ ] up
now i was talking to your mentality
you're not gonna bully me that's
gonna that's not gonna happen and you
know like jake if you and i ran into
each other
in the back alley in las vegas and i
wanted to do a homicide do it right now
though
right now someone's going to stop you
got like 27 people that's what i thought
yeah okay anyways i would do a homicide
on you if i wanted to
[Music]
dude wait is this the one yeah yeah yeah
oh god dude this clip is
money heard of jake paul
prior to accepting this fight but i
couldn't have told you a lot about
him or his brother i knew um you know he
kind of came up in his brother's shadow
he's trying to fill his brother's
footsteps
you know his brother is a lot more
talented at the larger following those
those type of things
you literally went on your instagram and
asked people
for roasts you asked people for roasts
on your instagram and that was the top
comment was say that his brother is
better than him
is he that's like that's like calling
kylie
jenner kendall jenner like i don't know
anything about them
anyways so that doesn't matter still a
compliment
i would love to be logan logan's a great
kid both stars
both taking over the world at a young
age okay so
when logan's little brother called me
out who's better you were him in boxing
me hands down that's why i'm three and
oh three kos he's oh
one and one yeah you ever whoop your ass
when you're the little brother
so i'll take that as he rubbed your face
in the carpet on a weekly basis
oh my god oh my god yeah sure
ben
dude jake can say whatever but we know
we know that one cut his ass deep
because jake doesn't stop
talking so the fact that something made
his brain start to compute
he got you just admit he got you
it is kind of funny that he he's like
that you got that from an instagram
comment
and he's like ben's like i don't i don't
really care i'm just
you can tell he's like i'm just doing it
because i you know i don't even want i'm
just gonna get paid for this fight and
that's all this is for it's for the
money
yeah for me it's like how old is he ben
he's like yeah mid-30s let's find out
you can just tell he's like i'm in there
i'm just
this is just a paycheck he's 36. he just
doesn't care
all it is he doesn't eat if anybody
loses even if he loses he's not gonna
give up a [ __ ]
not at all dude he had and people are
gonna try and put like
you know the gifts and everything he's
like i just don't care
dude uh there's a great clip
of two things one
jake tries to get under his skin by
repeatedly playing the
the jorge knee dude like you hold the
record and ben's like yeah i do hold the
record
yeah fastest knockout in the ufc he's
like jake i've seen it
i've actually seen it like a million
times i'm not insecure like you
so i don't care i know you're trying to
project your insecurity onto me but i
just don't care
and then jake is like holding it up and
it's like the knee just repeated over
and over and ben's just like yeah
yeah that's me getting neat in the head
it's like i saw it live
yeah saw it live saw the knee coming
towards my face
he's like that doesn't bother you he's
like no it happens
that's that's it no that's that's
fighting you get knocked the [ __ ] out
sometimes
i think the [ __ ] fight game that's a
[ __ ] fight game dude
this is the [ __ ] fight game that's
also
yeah that's also funny because again ben
has been in
30 pressers or whatever like actual
killers man
the other great thing was jorge was
tweeting about ben
you know and i was kind of i i didn't
like speak highly of ben uh going into
their fight because
i just like kind of bought into a media
narrative but
ben goes jorge i've kind of bit my
tongue on this for a while but
you're welcome you got one of the
luckiest hits
and uh that made your career if it
wasn't for that
you would still he's like like uh
he says i'm like you lost to usman and
you're gonna lose again so beat it loser
oh my god so then everyone is just now
like
oh yeah now that you think about it like
if he didn't need ben
then he wouldn't have got the bmf fight
with nate diaz and like all he did was
prolong his fall off
cause then he fought marty and he got
beat up and he's probably gonna
like already ben just changed the
narrative on that whole thing
it's not like mma fans are like that's
kind of true
wow
[Laughter]
this is great a little renaissance for
ben askren yeah i mean
i think jake underestimated ben askren's
[ __ ] talking
because ben can be just as annoying i
guess that's what i mean is that like
his nonchalantless is more like i don't
give a [ __ ]
is almost more annoying than if he were
to take the same approach that jake is
where he's like
chirping hard cause jake's like
yelling at him like this is the fight
game like
shut up like do it right now like
threatening to fight on stage or
whatever
and ben's sort of like dude i don't care
about this
yeah it's not real to me it's almost
way more annoying i feel like and i feel
like it's doing a better job of like
selling the fight oh for sure dude i
want to watch it now because
of ben's attitude i i like i wish
i wish ben would just be like jake
you're not a real fighter
you're not like if you just kept
repeating that over and over i feel like
that would just
crush him mentally you're not a real
fighter dude
so you fought three fights there are
guys an amateur with like 20 fights
you're not a real fighter man
this is the [ __ ] fight game dude
so funny yeah i mean
you know we'll see what happens i just
think uh
you know someone's gonna win someone's
gotta win
someone's definitely gonna win and
someone's gonna lose for sure someone's
probably gonna lose as well if someone
wins then i'm gonna
i'm guaranteeing that someone loses too
yeah
someone's definitely gonna lose yeah
someone's gonna lose
so hard dude someone's going to lose
like [ __ ] dude
someone's going to get [ __ ] l
l someone's going to get held so hard
so good oh so good
oh someone's gonna lose so good
i can't wait till [ __ ] jake wins and
you guys all have to see that mma gets
held so hard
yeah mma is over dude dude mma is
[ __ ] held and cancelled after this
mma is actually cancelled yeah
we're canceling mma mma is cancelled um
because it's gonna take two l's
that i can't wait for it dude
the the big brains what's the date of
that fight april
promote a little bit april 17th okay
cool just like
let me see if i got some screenshots
there were some pretty funny
big brain takes on those threads about
ben
just comically um
uh oh yeah this one killed me
if jp trashes aspirin then ufc is a joke
and boxing
is superior nice man nice
you nailed it hell yeah espn needs this
guy
it's kind of a funny like it's kind of a
funny thing to even argue like they're
two entirely different sports i know
this one killed me all things being
equal
no shot take a top striker in boxing
first top
bjj fighter and your striker as soon as
he hits the ground
would be a huge disadvantage this is one
of those like gracie like ground always
wins guys
yeah like i know this dude is like tying
up his ghee as he's
like typing this [ __ ] out no [ __ ]
shot dude
come on take him to the floor opening up
take him down
rubbing the opening of his ski he
watches the fights in his key
oh if they could go to the floor right
now bro [ __ ]
love to see a little wrestling putting
his foot behind his head
just being flexed oh my god dude
they could just [ __ ] go to the
[ __ ] floor right now
[ __ ] take him to the floor the only type
of dudes that want
that while watching a fight
[Laughter]
everyone else oh no don't go to the
floor no
yeah punch him in the [ __ ] face yeah
i i love when like two like you know ufc
fighting two guys go to the floor and
instantly the crowd is just drunk and so
i was like oh
no
17 hot dog for this
[Laughter]
big hot dog and watch two guys beat each
other in the face
you